every day we enter the cbs lot in that
gate right behind me and we
drive past the outstretched arms of kobe
bryant
once again the world is celebrating the
lakers legend
as his wife vanessa continues to
struggle with his untimely passing
you guys are on a lot of red carpet yeah
we are we are
we have fun with it this is a really
historic moment i'm so happy for him
this is such an honor for him vanessa
shared this photo with kobe
in a heart-wrenching message on what
would have been his 42nd birthday
i'm mad i didn't go first she writes it
should have been me
i wish i could make you your fave food
or a birthday cake
with my gigi i miss your big hugs your
kisses
your smile kobe's 17 year old daughter
natalia
shared a snapshot of her dad holding her
as a baby on his lap
and the emotional kobe video tributes
poured in
the lakers the dodgers a-rod truly the
mindset of a champion
nike kobe taught us to be better see me
wake up every single day to get better
today than you were yesterday
snoop dogg posted this video on the
court with kobe
and this footage of lebron james singing
happy birthday to kobe
on his 30th birthday hit 5 million
instagram views this morning
i want to say it's a bad dream former
laker matt barnes who sat down with e.t
after kobe's death shared this video of
his new tattoo of kobe and gigi
i want to say everything but kobe's gone
and there's news about vanessa's lawsuit
against the pilot and the helicopter
company
regarding that crash in january killing
kobe gigi
and seven others the pilot's brother had
asked for a change of venue to orange
county
citing kobe's popularity in l.a a judge
denied that
in court papers obtained by e.t
vanessa's legal team argued
there is no county line at which kobe
bryant's celebrity
suddenly evaporates